can you elaborate on the role of what is
private intelligence and what's the role
of private intelligence in the scope of
all the intelligence that is gathered
and used in the United States yeah
absolutely it's a it's something that so
few people know about and it became a
more mainstream topic with the Trump
Administration
because Trump made it no secret that he
was going to hire private intelligence
organizations to run his intelligence
operations and fund them so that really
brought it to the mainstream but going
all the way back to 911 going all the
way back to 2001 when when the 9 11
attacks happened there was a commission
that was formed
to determine the reasons that 911
happened and among the lists that they
determined of course they found out that
the intelligence Community wasn't
coordinating well with each other there
were Fife Dums and there was infighting
and there wasn't good Intel sharing
but more than that they identified that
we were operating uh at Cold War levels
even though we were living in a time
when terrorism was the new biggest
threat to National Security
so the big recommendation coming out of
the 911 Commission was that the
intelligence organizations the
intelligence Community significantly
increased the presence of intelligence
operators overseas and in terms of
analytical capacity here in the United
States
when they made that decision it
completely destroyed it totally was
incongruent with the existing hiring
process because the existing hiring
process for CIA or NSA is a six to nine
month process the only way they could
plus up their size is fast enough
was to bypass their own hiring and
instead go direct to private
organizations so naturally the
government contracted with the companies
that they already had secure contracts
with Boeing Raytheon Northrop Grumman
khaki you know you name it and then over
time from 2001 to now or I guess that
started really in 2004 when they started
significantly increasing their private
the presence of private Intelligence
Officers uh from there from then until
now it's become a budgetary thing it's
become uh it's become a continuity of
operations thing and now the reason
Northern Virginia has become one of the
wealthiest
ZIP codes in America is because of the
incredible concentration of private
intelligence that is supporting CIA NSA
Dia FBI and all the slew of IC Partners
uh by the way does volunteer play a role
in this palantir is one of those
organizations that that was trying to
pitch their product to an intelligence
Community because they have it's a
fantastic product on paper
um but the challenge was the proprietary
Services the proprietary systems that we
current that we used in CIA prior to
palantir
continued to outperform palantir
so just like any other business decision
if you've got homegrown systems that
outperform external systems and it's not
worth it to share the internal
information
got it so what uh the close connection
between Peter Thiel and Donald Trump did
that have a role to play in the
um in Donald Trump's leveraging of
private intelligence there's that
completely disjoint I think that they're
related but only
um circumstantially because remember
Donald Trump wasn't really investing in
CIA
so the last thing he wanted to do was
spend his his network wasta wasta is a
term that we call influence it's an
Arabic term for influence Trump didn't
want to use his wasp to putting teal
into CIA only to lose Teal's contract as
soon as Trump left office so instead it
was more valuable to put Peter thiel's
tool to use in private intelligence and
then of course I think he nominated
Peter Thiel to be his Secretary of
Defense Secretary of State
at some point in time he tried to
present like presidentially appoint
Peter Thiel into a position of of uh
government Authority
what do you think of figures like
um like Peter Thiel do they wield and
I'm sure there's other figures of
similar
scale and and reach and Power in private
intelligence what do you think about
their role and Power
in this whole like without public
accountability yeah that you would think
directors of CIA perhaps have so this is
where private intelligence has both a
strength and a weakness
the ultimate law overriding that that's
overseeing private intelligence is not
is not
um government legislation
it's the law of economics if they
produce a superior product then they
will have a buyer if they do not produce
a superior product they will not have a
buyer and that's a very simple business
principle
whereas in the current national security
infrastructure you can create a crap
product but the taxpayer dollars are
always going to be spent
so it's really thrown things for a loop
especially during the Trump
Administration and this is one of the
things that I will always say I liked
about the Trump Administration it shown
it put a big blazing bright light on all
of the flaws within our system
one of those flaws being this executive
power over the intelligence
organizations and the lack of the of
accountability for intelligence
organizations to produce a superior
product
uh
when that light got shown down
that's when you also saw Trump start to
go after if you remember there was a
period where he was taking security
clearances away from retiring officers
that became a big hot issue that became
something that people were very opposed
to
when they didn't realize that that that
process of taking security clearances
away that incentivized seasoned senior
officers to stay in service
because with private intelligence paying
a premium during the Trump
administration because Trump was paying
a premium to the private intelligence
world
when when senior officers found that it
was more profitable to retire early keep
their clearance and go work for Raytheon
Trump saw that as bypassing service to
the American people you've made a career
in CIA you've made a career in NSA you
should stay there if you leave you lose
your clearance because you no longer
have a need to know
he upset the apple cart with that and
unfortunately the narrative that came
out in many ways was a negative
narrative against Trump when in fact he
was actually doing quite a service to
the American people trying to take take
away the incentive of senior officials
leaving their service in order to just
profits here in the private Intel
enforce so in that way he was kind of
supporting the the CIA in in making sure
that competent people and experienced
people stay and say our incentivizes
stay there correct I think that there
was there was definitely he understood
incentives I mean Donald Trump
understands incentives
um so he was in trying to incentivize
them to stay but I think he was also
playing a safety card because he didn't
want former CIA officials who were not
listening to him to then move into
private Intel organizations that he may
be hiring only to then have them
undermine him from both sides of the of
the coin so there was a little bit of of
offensive uh calculation in there as
well but do the Dynamics and the
incentives of Economics that you
referred to that the private
intelligence operates under is that more
or less ethical than the forces
that maybe government agencies operate
under like what's your intuition is
capitalism lead so you mentioned at
least two maximizations of efficiency
and performance but is that correlated
with
ethical behavior when we're talking
about
such hairy activities like collection of
intelligence the question of Ethics is a
great question so let me let me start
this whole thing out by saying CIA hires
people
on a on a spectrum of our ability to be
morally flexible
ethically flexible
all people at their heart are ethically
flexible
I would never punch somebody in the face
right some people out there would say I
would never hurt another human being
but as soon as a human being posed a
direct threat to their daughter or their
son or their mother now all of a sudden
they're going to change their ethical
stance in self-defense
right but at the end of the day it's
still hurting another hurting another
person so what CIA looks for is people
who are able to swing across that that
Spectrum
for lesser offenses right more
flexibility
I do not believe that private
intelligence and the laws of Economics
lend themselves to increased ethics or
increased ethical behavior in the short
term
but what ends up happening is that in
the long term
in order to scale economic benefits you
are forced to act within Norms of your
customer base so as the Norms of that
customer base dictate certain
requirements
the company has to adapt to those
requirements in order to continue to
scale
so if if a company tries to ostracize
lgbtq or if they try to ostracize men or
ostracized women they're limiting their
ability to grow economically they have
to adapt to whatever is the prevailing
ethical requirement of their customer
base that's such an interesting question
because you you look a big Farmer in the
pharmaceutical companies
and they have a quite a poor reputation
in the public eye and some of it maybe
much of it is deserved at least
historically speaking and so you start
to wonder well can intelligence agencies
use some of the same technique to
manipulate the public
like what they believe about those
agencies in order to maximize profit as
well sort of finding shortcuts or
unethical
paths that allow you to not be
ultimately
responsible to the customer absolutely
and I would go a step further to say
that the covert nature of intelligence
operations
is really attractive
when it comes to the private sector
because now they have all the same money
with none of the oversights and all they
have to do is deliver
so without the oversight what's holding
you back and in in a lot of for anybody
who's ever run a business anybody's ever
started a startup or tried to make
something succeed we all know that there
come those times where you have to
skirt the boundaries of proprietary of
propriety or uh or morality or
commitments or promises to other people
because at the end of the day if your
business fails it's on you
so
if you promise to deliver something to a
client you've got to deliver to the
client even if that means you stay up
late or if you lie on your taxes
whatever it might be there's there's a
certain level of do or die yeah I
personally have a sort of optimistic
view that ultimately the best way
is to stay within ethical balance kind
of like what you suggested if you want
to be a company that's extremely
successful is uh when with competence
not with cheating because cheating won't
I believe win in the long term
but uh
in terms of being publicly responsible
to your decisions I mean I've already
been supposed to talk to Peter Thiel
twice on this podcast and it's just been
complicated if I were to put myself into
shoes
why do podcasts the the risk is too high
to be a public person at all and so I
totally understand that at the same time
I think if you're doing things by the
book and you're the best in the world at
your job
um that you have nothing to worry about
and you can advertise that and you
recruit you help recruit I mean that's
the
that's the work of capitalism is you
want to advertise that
um
this is the place where the best people
in the world at this thing work
true I think that you're point of view
is accurate I would also say that
they're
the complexities of what makes somebody
make a decision
can only really be properly calculated
with a baseline so because there is no
Baseline that you or I have on Peter
Thiel it's difficult to really ascertain
why he does or doesn't accept invites or
why he does or doesn't appear